[Musique]
si je vous dis chimil vous me répondez
ok moi c'est pour baiser des meufs mais
plein
beaucoup c'est
bien on a pe rque mais on peut
s'arranger on débloque un peu de Tun on
se fait une
collect tellement gros pourquoi tu es là
toi mais moi j'ai tué mon frère
[Musique]
moi c'est Paris en tant cul sans te
demander l'autorisation si on est là
quoi en fait tu t'y attendais pas mais
ça y est on est tous là avec les copains
quoi regard les voitures et
tout on est avec les copains on est avec
les
voitures use pas ta
mère descuse
pas-moi tu es un bonhomme ou tu es une
fette regarde-moi regarde-moi mon
dieux la [__] la sal la put du quartier
[__]
la pardon Wes quoi
ok le mec est tend d'Ax
[Musique]
OK le mec est tendx en ce
moment l'heure ça inér je m'attendais
pas à ce qu' faut juste que je te dise
un truc quoi oh mais merde je l'
fais
mer les gars qui pent non
personne
bon
je la vois à 15h je la baise pour le CS
de l'Endre cou pote pardon pardon pardon
pardon ok cou pote te Mar pas [__]
décroche décoch décroche c'est quoi le
texte mental combat c'est 11
Dee ah bah oui c'est moins spectaculaire
mais il y a toujours l'idée de mort mais
voilà j'ai pas de réplique c'est raté
hein bah
oui monsieur zé
[Musique]
oui
tellement eu peur j'ai tellement eu peur
je non non pas la rivière pas la
rivière mais moi j'ai le nez quoi j'ai
eu le nez dans la bouche j'ai pas voulu
l'embrasser du coup j'ai baissé j'ai
dans la bouche improvisation c'est super
important dans les
morceaux c'est propre ça B ouais c'est
propre c'est
bon tu
[Applaudissements]
chiante con
[__] je suis venu avec une
[Musique]
copine ah c'est nul
ok coupé c'est bon allez
[Musique]
allez tu m'as dit je t'aime ouais mais
je crois que je pensais à un pote je
peut-être
metir on y va maintenant on y va
maintenant ou avec moi Ohain
[Musique]
[__] ça va rich
oui non c'est une erreur
ouiok et à ce moment-là entreraai par la
porte des poulets mais des flics hein
avec des vrais poulets dans des cornets
comme ça grillés on tapis
sur un tapis mais pas volant qu'il se
galérerait du coup ça prendrait du
retard au niveau de la
cérémonie et bien sûr qu'on a besoin des
Pokémon dans les années
90 toujours à se battre c'est
vrai j'en ai trouvé je connais
pas pas son
texte
je
[Musique]
t
allô j'ai inversé c'est le bêtisier ça
ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi